das ist der erfolgreichste und
meistverkaufte hubschrauber der welt der
ec135 und dabei schlüpft das multitalent
immer wieder in neue rollen sei es als
gelber engel in der luftrettung ode als
kommissar der lüfte bei der polizei aber
auch bei militärischen einsätzen oder
zum transport von wikis schraubt sich
der alleskönner in die luft und der
ec135 ist made in germany hier im
schwäbischen donauwörth wird das
erfolgsprodukt weiter entwickelt und
gebaut insgesamt 4.000 mitarbeiter sind
direkt oder indirekt mit der herstellung
dieses faszinierenden flug objektes
beschäftigt ein wichtiges element stellt
hierbei der kabinen bau dar entsprechend
behutsam wird gearbeitet
im gegensatz zur automobilherstellung
wird hier ausschließlich noch mit hand
gefertigt viele schrauben und nieten
werden sogar noch zusätzlich mit einer
drahtschlinge abgesichert entsprechend
personalintensiv und zeitaufwendig
gestaltet sich der zusammenbau
[Musik]
in diesem bereich wird später mal der
speise tank installiert sein
in diesem bereich hier der haupttag der
man sieht auf jeden fall wir haben hier
die verschiedenen materialien haben
aluminium wir haben kohlefaser die wozu
einander verbunden werden das hat sich
im laufe der zeit verändert wir haben
früher immer die hubschrauber gehabt es
sind aus stahl und vorwiegend aluminium
worden jetzt haben wir die neuen
rohstoffe wie kohle phase glasfaser
aluminium die verbindung die
übereinander zueinander gefügt werden um
einen einsatz auch bei extremen
witterungsverhältnissen und belastungen
zu garantieren wird das kabinen gerüst
von über 5.000 steck und
schraubverbindungen fixiert nach
mehreren arbeitsstunden zeichnet sich
bereits die position des piloten ab
und genauer ins detail zu gehen
wird hier später mal der pilot sitzen
zu meiner linken der co-pilot hier in
diesem bereich wenn sie immer die türen
befinden links und rechts und hinten die
schiebetüren und genau hier in diesem
bereich die fenster
nun erfolgt die so genannte hochzeit im
kabinen baum der hintere teil des
chassis wird auf die bodenplatte
aufgesetzt und vermietet auch hier sind
für jeden handgriff spezialisten am werk
der kleinste fehler kann nicht nur teuer
sondern auch tödlich sein
unsere männlichen kollegen jederzeit
möglich und auch gerne gesehen im
anschluss wird das führerhaus mit der
bodengruppe verbunden spätestens jetzt
kann man das gesicht der neuen ec 135
erahnen jeder griff und arbeitsschritt
basiert auf einem langen
entwicklungsprozess der nicht nur die
flugtauglichkeit sondern auch der
arbeitsprozess muss minutiös geplant und
entwickelt werden
hierzu kommt absolutes high tech in der
entwicklungsabteilung ans werk hier
sitzt das herz und die zukunft von
eurocopter
entwicklungschef alexander engleder
zeigt die wichtigsten schritte in der
planung eines hubschraubers auf
wenn man mit der entwicklung eines
hubschraubers beginnt ja dann überlegt
man sie ja welches marktsegment man
bedienen möchte das ergibt dann eine
abflug masse wenn man diese abflug maße
kennt dann muss man sich überlegen wie
viel leistung in kilowatt der mps muss
ich ihnen dieses produkt installieren
damit ich schweben kann also werde ich
als allererstes mir überlegen welche
triebwerke oder wie groß muss die die
triebwerksleistung seien und wo kann ich
die triebwerke unterbringen wenn ich das
weiß welche sieht man ein triebwerk
worauf anderen seite ist rechte in
flugrichtung gesehen dann fängt man als
nächstes an sich zu überlegen was
brauche ich denn für einen haupt rutter
der hauptrunde ist ja das tragwerk bei
einem hubschrauber das was bei einem
pflegen flieger die tragflächen sind es
bei dem hubschrauber der der hauptrouten
heißen die dinge auch drei flüge ja und
ich muss mir dann überlegen was brauche
ich für einen rotordurchmesser was
brauche ich für eine rot der drehzahl
damit die blätter
so gestaltet werden können dass sie den
auftrieb liefern der notwendig ist das
ja war auf der anderen seite auch nicht
ermüden und brechen werden und dafür
sind die männer von der
rotorblattproduktion verantwortlich
und wir arbeiten hier mit kohlefaser
das mit einem hartz system gedrängt ist
viele glauben ja dass uns der
rotorblätter aus metall bestehen aber
unsere platte bestehen zum größten teil
aus kunststoff
dass er ist ein einzel zuschnitt für die
ec135 wir werden das später sehen wir
diesen einflüssen einlegen und auch hier
sind ausschließlich experten mit viel
fingerspitzengefühl gefragt eine
maschine könnte diesen anspruchsvollen
und diffizilen arbeitsprozess nicht
übernehmen
im nächsten schritt wird auf der living
schneideanlage in der evoque sie das
getränk das glasfasergewebe in schmale
streifen zugeschnitten daraus entsteht
im späteren schritt der sogenannte flex
team der kern des ec 135 rotorblattes
und das diesen schmalen streifen
entstehen anschließend unser
rotorblätter
der bau gleicht einer sisyphos arbeit
aus kleinsten textil ähnlichem streifen
soll nun ein massives rotorblatt mit
kern entstehen
nun wird die zuvor zugeschnittenen
einzeln lagen in die sogenannte hall
form eingelegt dabei muss man sich
vorstellen dass in summe
126 einzeln lagen übereinander gelegt
werden und das insgesamt mal 8
das harz wird bei der erwärmung ungefähr
genau so flüssig wie wasser nun findet
die große lothar blatt hochzeit statt
der zuvor ausgehärtete holen wird nun in
die unterform des ec 135 rotorblattes
eingelegt
im weiteren schritt kommen noch
zusätzliche komponenten wie abstimmen
lassen sein gewicht
mit in die form
hier sind wir nun fast schon am ende der
sogenannten roten fertigung in dieser
form werden nun die zuvor gefertigten
einzelkomponenten eingelegt und zu einem
sehr stabilen bauteil gefügt im nächsten
schritt wird dann eine ober form auf die
unter form gestimmt und wir werden das
super blatt bei einer temperatur von 135
grad aushalten man kann es sich
vorstellen wenn man das ganze in einen
backofen schiebt und dann letztendlich
das rotorblatt final entsteht
und hier ist der spezial backofen eine
maschine die eigens für die
rotorblattfertigung entwickelt wurde mit
dem kran wird nun die oper form auf die
unter form gesetzt
und somit die hohlform geschlossen in
den nächsten schritt wird dann über eine
hydraulik die form fest verschlossen um
dann den der finalen außerhalb der
prozess zu starten die auswertung dauert
ca 16 stunden bei einem ec 135 wollen
nach dem öffnen der presse sehen wir das
nun vollständig ausgehärtet rotorblatt
in den weiteren schritten wird nun das
sogar blatt beschnitten und versäumt und
letztendlich dann in die oberfläche
gegeben wo es eine vom kunden gewünschte
farbe erhält alle bauteile vom rotor bis
hin zum bedienungselemente oder
triebwerk können im vorfeld durch ein
computerprogramm visualisiert und auf
ihre funktion und anfälligkeit getestet
werden auf diese möglichkeit kann man
jedoch erst seit rund zehn jahren
zurückgreifen
früher was der frühere hubschrauber
konstruiert haben wird ein zeichenbrett
mit tusche da ist man sehr früh in einen
prototypen steigungen dann gegangen und
hatte über versuche über ausprobieren
dann das produkt optimiert an der
hardware und wir sind heute in der lage
über diese modernen
virtuellen konstruktions modelle die es
gibt ja sowas bezeichnet man als cad
sehr viele verhaltensweisen des
hubschraubers virtuell zu simulieren wir
brauchen nicht mehr die aufwändige
prototypenphase von von anfang an und
wir sind dadurch in der lage dass wir
schneller produkte auf den markt bringen
die wiege des hubschraubers liegt im
fünfzehnten jahrhundert das multitalent
leonardo da vinci hat bereits erste
zeichnungen für einen hubschrauber
angefertigt richtig in die luft jedoch
ging das fluggerät erst anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts in der folge
wurden unterschiedliche antriebs und
schlug konstruktionen gebaut
federführend waren hier in erster linie
deutsche und französische konstrukteure
doch erst 1922 brachte et ermöglichen
den ersten zuverlässigen drehflügler mit
heckrotor in die luft ein meilenstein im
hubschrauber bau
später wurden noch zahlreiche teilweise
sehr eigenartige unspektakulär anmutende
konstruktionen in den himmel geschraubt
doch auch 100 jahre später wird der
hubschrauber immer wieder neu erfunden
und sei es nur um neue auflagen zu
erfüllen
also es gibt da zwei aspekte es gibt den
aspekt der ökologie und es gibt den
aspekt der sicherheit
ja und beides können wir heute und auch
in zukunft durch eine bessere geeignete
verfahren rechenverfahren
konstruktionsverfahren bessere reden
dass man herkommt wie in der
automobilindustrie oder der herstellung
von flugzeugen wird also die
energieeinsparung eine der wichtigsten
herausforderungen in der entwicklung
neuer modelle seien
hierzu trägt gewiss auch der rotor bei
schließlich ist er kraft entfalte und
lärm erzeuger in einem
[Musik]
so muss der rotor der zukunft zum einen
einen höheren wirkungsgrad aber
gleichzeitig eine geringere
lärmemissionen vereinen
zuletzt werden unser logo blätter
lackiert dabei gibt es sehr komplexe
lackierungen wie auch einfache
lackierungen bis hin zu spiralen
lackierungen wir orientieren uns hier
ganz nach dem kundenwunsch nach
über 100 arbeitsschritten ist das
rotorblatt schließlich fertig für die
einen nur ein blatt für die anderen
hightech in vollendung
das werk ist vollbracht in unserem motto
plug stecken und unglaublich 130
arbeitsstunden und jetzt geht es ab in
die endmontagelinie in der endmontage
wird dann bis zu 20 hubschraubern
gleichzeitig gearbeitet wer glaubt hier
auf den ersten roboter zu stoßen der ist
auch in der fertigungslinie wird alles
von hand eingesetzt montage beginnt hier
die harte arbeit das heißt die
mitarbeiter müssen hier bohren schleifen
nieten beschläge installieren und das
alles immer dem kundenwunsch
entsprechend die hauptaufgabe besteht
neben der drecksarbeit natürlich auch
wieder sauber zu machen denn dvd das
heißt sauberkeit qualität wird bei uns
als eurocopter sehr groß geschrieben
hatte ein hubschrauber vor 50 jahren in
erster linie mechanische elemente und
steuerungen steht heute die elektronik
im vordergrund entsprechend aufwendig
gestaltet sich die installation
nach dass schmutz arbeit gilt es die
elektrokabel zu integrieren wie
integrieren vier kilometer bis zwölf
kilometer kabel dabei müssen die
mitarbeiter in für pin die ganzen
strecke verbindungen verbinden und wenn
man sich den planern sieht der immer
kundenspezifische aussieht das ganze
sehr sehr sehr schwer zu lesen und dafür
braucht es schon unsere fachleute unsere
spezialisten hier befinden wir uns beim
gehirn des hubschraubers hier werden
alle systeme angesteuert der rechner
sieht etwas anders aus wie bei ihnen
daheim er muss bis zu 100 verschiedene
systeme an steuern und wenn da was
schief läuft dann haben wir wirklich ein
problem bei dem hubschrauber die system
verwendung hängt vom kunden ab das geht
von dem vip kunden der ipod einstecken
will über die polizei mission eine
wärmebildkamera benutzt wird so dass
sogar ein militärischer einsatz oder wir
wollen zum beispiel ein handy orten
gerade im polizeieinsatz haben sich die
multifunktionalen ausstattungsvarianten
und anbaumöglichkeiten des ec 135
bewährt inzwischen hat sich das modell
bundesweit als polizeihubschrauber
durchgesetzt
bayern wurde als erstes bundesland mit
dieser fliegenden hochtechnologie
ausgerüstet und konnte frühzeitig die
ersten einsätze trainieren der chef der
staffel joachim walzik weist das
fluggerät zu schätzen
das ist ein neuer hubschrauber ec135 der
polizeihubschrauberstaffel bayern wir
haben acht stück seit dem jahr 2010
jetzt neu ausgestattet mit neuester
technologie
die hat wie die vorgänger bereits ein
zweimotoriger hubschrauber ist mit
vielen zusatzausstattungen ausrüstbar
und allem kann man der rettungswinde
anbauen für unsere einsätze im gebirge
man kann unten an last haken montieren
um feuerlösch behälter anzuhängen bei
katastropheneinsätzen wir haben hier die
zusatzausstattungen angebaut man sieht
ja echt gut man kann hier unten den
scheinwerfer sehen mit dem man ein
ganzes fußballfeld ausleuchten kann wir
weisen damit auch kollegen ein wenn man
eine person im wald gefunden haben wir
sehen hier sehr gute wärmebildkamera mit
video und low light kamera mit laser
eschweiler und etlichen technischem
equipment um dem einsatz insbesondere
bei nacht zu optimieren wir haben eine
ganze reihe von antennen die man ja
unten erkennen für
file systemen für live bildübertragung
und ähnliches equipment durch die
entwicklung der technologie sowie der
einsatz neuer materialien elektronik und
software hat sich auch das flugverhalten
und die manövrierfähigkeit der
hubschrauber enorm verändert zudem sind
die hubschrauber der neuen generation
bei weitem nicht mehr so windanfällig
und können daher auch bei schlechter
witterung besser gesteuert werden auch
der pilot wird bei seiner arbeit im
cockpit durch eine vielzahl von
elektronischen hilfsmitteln entlastet
und abgesichert davon konnte man vor 40
jahren nur träumen
also in den 70er jahren und 80er jahren
da waren die hübsche aber noch ohne
große elektronische unterstützung zu
fliegen da war außerdem hydraulik
systeme an bord noch viel handarbeit
gefordert dass der pilot musste bereits
vom abheben bis zum absetzen am boden
wieder permanent die hände am steuer
haben wo hast du denn hubschrauber
permanent führen war ein hubschrauber
fliegt ich so freiwillig da ist nicht so
stabil dass permanent der handarbeit
gefordert bei den neuen geräten haben
wir ein autopilot drin das heißt der
pilot kann im anflug bereits sich auf
seinen einsatz konzentrieren am
einsatzort weil er den an- und abflug
die nato pilot den hubschrauber fliegen
lässt die elektronische stabilisierung
systeme an bord dass der hubschrauber
würde auch so in der lage gehalten und
man muss nicht permanent mit der hand in
dazu zwingen in der fluglage zu bleiben
wenn wir das gerne hätte
dennoch sind die ansprüche an die crew
nicht gesunken im gegenteil mit den
zusätzlichen elektronischen
einrichtungen wie zum beispiel
wärmebildkamera oder nachtsicht brillen
wird der einsatz auf zur doppelbelastung
insofern ist nicht jeder dem job als
pilot oder ingenieur an bord gewachsen
einer von 30 piloten bei der
hubschrauberstaffel in bayern ist
manfred sache er ist sich seiner
verantwortung und auch der täglichen
herausforderung bei riskanten einsätzen
durchaus bewusst und kennt daher seinen
arbeitsplatz blind
kann ich die richtung des hubschraubers
angeben
gleichzeitig habe habe ich meine linke
hand am pitch das ist der kollektive
platz der stellhebel mit diesem hebel
kann ich die einstellung der blätter
verändern
ganz pauschal gesagt je mehr ich an
diesen hebel ziehen um so mehr auftrieb
hat der hubschrauber zur verfügung
und da sich das hubschrauber platte riet
wenn dann der hubschrauber der boden
verlässt würde sich die zelle versuchung
abzustützen die gegenrichtung zu drehen
das heißt ich muss gleichzeitig den
heckrotor ansteuern dass also der
hubschrauber nicht im stand versuchung
würde sich zu drehen wir haben eine
elektronische landkarte diese landkarte
können hier wäre sachen mit einblenden
den gelben punkt wo sie jetzt so eben
sehen das ist ein altes luftfahrzeug was
ich gerade im landeanflug befindet die
rot blinkenden sachen sind hinter diese
die auch für unsere flug relevant sein
könnten und auch das blaue
beziehungsweise ich glaube das ist es
worum leitungen und ich konzentriere
mich für flugführung eigentlich mehr auf
diesem bereich hier also ich kann hier
auch nochmal den kurs anzeigen lassen
hier habe ich so einen künstlichen
horizont die höhe wird mir angezeigt und
auch die geschwindigkeit
diese instrumente sind so ein triebwerk
überwachen also wie viel leistung nicht
von den triebwerken abfahren
öl temperaturen und drücke werden wir
angezeigt hier
da oben sind so ist im online panel das
heißt also wenn hier irgendwie eine
warnleuchte
aufleuchten würde müsste ich sofort
reagieren und sofortige maßnahmen
einleiten
da sind so groß also sicherungen die wir
angezeigt werden oder sache worauf ich
reagieren muss und das blaue ist es
beispielsweise die tankfüllung wir
stehen jetzt hier mit 370 kilo oder 368
km hauptbank das wird zwei stunden
bei einsätzen von wärmebild und tv
kamera wird die crew auf drei personen
aufgestockt dann kommt andrea motschmann
zum einsatz als operator in hat sie sich
auf die sensiblen erkennungs techniken
spezialisiert so ist die crew in der
lage zu jeder tages und nachtzeit mit
unterschiedlichsten methoden vermisste
oder täter aufzuspüren
die mannschaft an bord ist hierbei ein
eingespieltes team und tastet sich oft
millimetergenau an ihr ziel heran
[Musik]
meine aufgabe als operator es im heli
die kamera zu bedienen die tagsüber tv
kamera und in der nacht infrarotkamera
und eben die einsätze zu dokumentieren
täter zu verfolgen
[Musik]
fahrzeuge im auge zu behalten
und das ganze dann natürlich auch
nahaufnahmen festzuhalten ich habe vier
zoomstufen für tele stufen damit kann
ich in der regel
schon das gesicht direkt aufnehmen von
dem täter oder irgendeiner person und
genau erkennen also kann auch so scharf
stellen dass man wirklich alles erkennt
tagsüber natürlich auch in farben und
nachts kann ich auch so scharf stellen
dass man konturen bad
form alles haare auch die struktur von
klamotten erkennen kann aber auch bei
rettungseinsätzen insbesondere im
gebirge ist der polizeihubschrauber
unverzichtbar wie hier werden menschen
aus einer festsitzenden seilbahngondel
höhe über dem abgrund ist dies nur noch
mit dem helikopter möglich
doch auch er stößt an seine grenzen
bei sturmböen muss selbst ein ec 135 den
einsatz abbrechen
zurück bei eurocopter in donauwörth
einer der aufwendigsten prozesse steht
kurz bevor der einbau der beiden power
triebwerke der ec135 ist eines von
wenigen modellen seiner größe das über
zwei triebwerke verfügt eine auflage die
an polizei und rettungshelikopter in
deutschland gestellt wird hier erfolgt
gerade die hochzeit des motors mit dem
hubschrauber
830 psg engine werden jetzt an
hubschrauber installiert sodass die
maschine ihre volle power entfalten kann
ein engine ein triebwerk kostet circa
250.000 euro das heißt mit beiden
triebwerken befindet sich genau eine
halbe million hubschrauber der ganze
hubschrauber kostet dann je nach
ausstattungsvariante ab 5 millionen euro
aufwärts militärische exemplare können
schon mal den betrag von acht millionen
euro überschreiten letztlich ist jedes
dieser produkte ein unikat denn keine
ausstattungsvariante gleicht der anderen
lediglich der sogenannte fan est on ist
bei allen ec 135 identisch während
herkömmliche heck rotoren maximal sechs
rotorblätter besitzen haben fans
zwischen 8 und 18 blätter
hier befinden wir uns bei dem
markenzeichen von eurocopter unser
tennis thron die vorteile vom
tennis-thron sie leben der
lärmreduzierung auch der schutz bei
rettungsmissionen da der rotor
innenliegend ist und keiner von roter
erschlagen werden kann wie sie sehen ist
hier alles sehr sehr leicht was glauben
sie was der hubschrauber mit all der
technik mit den all den triebwerken mit
all den systemen liegt
auf jeden fall weniger wie ein vw golf
in der endfertigung bekommt der
hubschrauber nun seine krone aufgesetzt
insgesamt vier rotorblätter sollen ihn
zukünftig kraftvoll vertikal und
horizontal antreiben jedes dieser
blätter wurde im vorfeld intensiv auf
einem prüfstand in allen tempi und
anstellwinkel getestet wie alle bauteile
ist auch das rotorblatt mit nicht einmal
20 kilo überraschend leicht
die wichtigste komponente an unserem
hubschrauber ist das rotorblatt das
rotorblatt verhält sich ähnlich wie das
wieder autoreifen ja muss ausgerüstet
sein und es muss im gleichen spiel auf
verlaufen dafür bedarf es sehr viel
einstell arbeit schon im vorfeld bevor
der mitarbeiter das rotorblatt überhaupt
aufbauen kann nach dem aufbau der
rotorblätter werden die rotorblätter
noch zueinander während dem boden lauf
ausgerichtet es ist soweit der vogel
darf endlich fliegen und wird auf das
testgelände geschoben denn bis der heli
zu seinem einsatzort überstellt wird
kommt er noch unter die regie der
testpiloten
jetzt kann und muss die ec135 zeigen was
sie kann sie wird von chef testpilot
volker bau mit all seinem können an die
grenzen gebracht
in einem festgelegten ablauf und punkte
plan werden bestimmte flugmanöver und
flugsituationen getestet
[Musik]
bis jetzt
nicht selten
entsteht
[Musik]
doch nicht jeder bekommt die
verantwortungsvolle aufgabe übertragen
die ersten flüge der maschinen zu
steuern nur die besten ihrer zunft
dürfen sich als testpiloten an den
steuerknüppel setzen
[Musik]
der testflug verläuft ohne probleme
und wieder kann eine neue ec 135 vom
hangar in donauwörth zu seinem neuen
bestimmungsort fliegen alle drei tage
verlässt eine maschine in deutschlands
einziger flugzeug schmiede das werk made
in germany für einen weltweiten einsatz